des couleurs vives des récompenses tout
pour accrocher les jeunes
fortnite compte plus de 250 millions de
joueurs dans le monde
certains seraient même devenus
dépendants qui avancent étaient pas du
tout agressif sacré pas maintenant et ça
qui font des coups dans le mur il y a
plein d'autres histoires qu'on a entendu
là ils veulent pas aller aux toilettes
donc ils restent il reste il joue puis
des témoignages de la sorte cette
avocate en a recueilli des centaines
depuis la demande d'action collective
déposée au Québec contre le concepteur
Epic Games un juge de la course
supérieure vient de l'autoriser on vient
leur reprocher c'est d'avoir
commercialisé et mise en marché un
produit nocif sans en avoir divulgué les
risques même si on peut lire dans le
jugement qu'il manque encore d'études
sur la cyber dépendance le juge s'appuie
sur une comparaison forte selon elle à
titre analogique les phénotype du tabac
n'a pas été reconnu ennemi du jour au
lendemain férance avec entre le jeu
vidéo puis le cigarette c'est la
cigarette n'est jamais bonne alors qu'il
y a des côtés positifs aux jeux vidéo
tempère cette dépendance cette décision
permet toutefois de questionner le rôle
de l'industrie pour un problème reconnu
par l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
depuis 2019 l'industrie est souvent
subventionnée pour Epic Games au Québec
en subventionne beaucoup l'industrie des
jeux vidéo et donc on peut se poser la
question quelle est leur part de
responsabilité et comment peuvent-ils
aider venir en aide aux jeunes
cyberdépendants c'est justement la
mission du centre d'hébergement le grand
chemin qui voit une hausse des demandes
depuis quelques années environ 3% des
jeunes seraient atteints selon cette
intervenant ça c'est déjà vu un enfant
qui se lance en bas d'une voiture
pendant qu'on va chez grand-maman qui a
pas l'Internet
bien qu'il soit gratuit le jeu fortnite
encouragerait la dépense excessive par
l'entremise de la monnaie virtuelle le
vibox l'autre volet de l'action
collective vise donc à récupérer les
sommes dépensées par ces jeunes lésés
ici Jacques Benoît Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]